The Cheesecake Factory everyone's
favorite mall chain restaurant what I
decided to do today is order one slice
of every single cheesecake that they
have to offer and see how many people it
takes to finish all of it right now we
have about 32 slices of cheesecake from
the Cheesecake Factory
that is thirty-eight thousand eight
hundred eighty calories approximately
and this is also what one thousand five
hundred and two grams of saturated fat
looks like it looks delicious
hopefully Ella feels the same way she's
gonna come in first and try to do some
major damage your challenge is to finish
it and you are allowed to call in backup
so I'm gonna say what you'll say oh no
what do you mean I can call it oh my god
I like it but I'm also like what so I
just can eat it yes mmm this is a dream
come true
mmm-hmm movie this one's my favorite
but this lime is good too what's this
one Apple birthday cake yellow you guys
so good they're all so good I need help
though I'm gonna see if Ashley's cream
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
how many cheesecakes is it I don't even
know
okay I've been here for about two
minutes and that's too much cheesecake
for me good luck no okay thank you for
stopping - Ellis cheesecake greens this
is every flavor of cheesecake from
Cheesecake Factory I'm taking a photo
I'm enticing people best day ever so
Jared just got a new kitten and he is
also helping us so are you a cheese
kingpin I love it yes grab my banana
Judas
I'm really glad I took a lactose film
please take a bite of cheesecake are you
eating some other snacks
what are you doing so I brought back
this scrumptious piece of cheesecake and
the other members of ladylike are
watching me eat it so now that's three
people - this one piece of cheesecake
was really good though cheesecake yay oh
my god more people we're doing really
well
this is a good day yeah oh yeah that's
really good oh yes I'm a fan of vanilla
bean I don't really have worried you
like fills you up so quickly
oh please God Kaitlyn come help me my
childhood dream was to just always have
it she's a whole cheesecake in front of
me and just be able to like dig games
like it mom oh I'm gonna call in some
more reinforcement video sir thank you
enjoy see you thank you I'm feeling good
about this challenge that I just feel
good about this booth I think that we
can take it to the finish line at your
block in the hole camera
this is the last Vance cheesecake we're
all so proud of you oh Jesus
you know we went in with a big dream eat
all the cheese cakes at the Cheesecake
Factory and we didn't do I feel good
about myself not really
what can I say that I've had all the
cheesecakes that Cheesecake Factory yes
and that's something you can never take
away from me
[Music]